now we were just talking about the
report on the economy and on Wednesday
the Chancellor will lay out an economic
update and mini budget if you like in an
attempt to try and shift focus to you
the much hopes for economic recovery now
to look ahead to what's coming up in
that this week we're joined by Labour's
chair Chancellor Annalise Dodds thank
you very much for being on the program
what are you hoping to see from the
Chancellor good morning well we're
really hoping that we will have a proper
back to work budget next week we really
need to have that proper package put in
place not just so that we can help
people if they become unemployed but
above all to prevent people becoming
unemployed in the first place obviously
we've seen that one-size-fits-all
approach being adopted by government to
removing the economic support schemes we
can already see the impacts of that
unemployment in the UK so it really
seems the Chancellor look abandon that
one-size-fits-all approach let's have an
approach which reflects the fact this is
an economic crisis which is affecting
sectors differently different sectors
really need that strong support now if
we put it in place then we won't see the
kind of mass unemployment that's
threatening our country currently I
wonder if a lot of what you're calling
for the government is already
effectively doing I mean you're saying
that you're hoping to see something
focus our unemployment we've been told
just a few moments ago by and that
Hancock that it's gonna be jobs jobs
jobs that we're going to be hearing
about on Wednesday and talking about the
one-size-fits-all approach well if you
look at what Ritchie seen at the
Chancellor has said just a week or so
ago he's called for direct fiscal
support to those particular industries
most effective so it does feel as if the
government is really looking at that
anyway well Sophie if they're looking at
it I'd be delighted because
unfortunately we have been calling for
many many weeks if not months for
government to change course around this
and quite frankly this is not the stage
to be looking at different forms of
support while people are already losing
their employment you know for a very
very long time we've been saying to
government that if they adopt
that one-size-fits-all approach to
removing support which it doesn't sound
like the Chancellor is looking like like
he's moving away from if they adopt that
approach then we will see higher levels
of unemployment and the redundancies
that we've seen over the last few days
do seem to be linked to that timetable
of the removal of support it's now is
not the time to be looking into
different measures it's the time to be
putting them into place and frankly our
country is behind lots of others on this
you know we will support the government
in putting the right measures into place
but they really need to be far speedier
at doing that we were talking as well to
the house secretary about more money for
the NHS reports he said he didn't
recognize that in the observer saying
the NHS England has asked for an extra
10 billion pounds to cover the cost of
fighting coronavirus does the NHS need
more money well a VB NHS really does
need that sustainable funding
settlements and one of our main concerns
is that of course we could well see very
sadly an additional wave of this disease
into the winter obviously that could be
associated also with flu cases the other
kinds of seasonal illnesses that we have
building up to the winter and it's
really important that the NHS has that
stability of funding so that it can plan
towards that eventualities you know if
we end up having to take measures at the
last minute that's obviously very
expensive in the short term and
therefore we do need to see that
sustainable funding we've also said that
government should be looking at for
example expanding the flu vaccination
program to over 50 so that we can try
and reduce that pressure on on the NHS
up to where
you know all sounds you know very
expensive the idea that we need more
support for people who may be losing
their jobs more money for the NHS and of
course the Chancellor will also be
looking at ways to try and raise money
for the treasury one thing that's been
floated as scrapping the triple lock on
pensions which means of course that they
have to rise by a certain amount at each
year would you support that well so I
would just say about the beginning of
your question actually a lot of this is
about queer money is targeted whether
it's going in the right direction we
have actually seen a number of decisions
taken by government which have been
relatively expensive and which happened
to leverage and arguably that's been the
case with some of the major contracts
around the health support that we've
seen particularly around the up for
example so we need to make sure that
that money is spent correctly we need to
have that sectoral approach which is
about targeting as much as it's about
the overall level of support on the
pensions triple lock now obviously there
is an issue there remains how salaries
are calculated and if we take into
account for example people who've seen
their IRAs reduced down to 80 percent it
wouldn't really be making sense to then
count that as one of the three elements
that binds back to normal pay afterwards
but you know this is a technical issue
for government to sort out it shouldn't
affect whether the triple lock applies
and it seems to me that different things
are getting mixed up in how government
is talking about this whether they're
committed to pensioners in the long term
I'm worried about whether they are or
not and the short term technical issues
about how you calculate the triple lock
which I'm sure government can deal with
I mean it's got statisticians it's got a
cannot economists who can look into this
and work out the figures for them
think about some of those long-term
issues neither labor nor the government
want to see a return to austerity that's
what we've been told and now earlier
this week you said that as part of the
new settlement the government should
think about introducing taxes on assets
rather than income so I'm just
interested what kind of assets are you
talking about you talking about savings
we're talking about houses watching well
Sophia if I could before I respond to
the very last bit of your question when
we've heard that there won't be any
return to the kinds of cuts that we've
seen recently actually local authorities
are looking many of them are potentially
having to share a fifth of their staff
within year if the current funding
settlement goes ahead so quite new to
entertain stances on the issue around
arraign taxation look I think it's
really important we've been through an
enormous sacrifice as a nation in many
case in it and it's very often been the
lowest paid people who've been
delivering for our country you know the
hospital porters the delivery drivers we
shouldn't end up in a situation where as
government has suggested in some
comments to the press that we could see
generalized tax rises across the whole
population I think that would be wrong I
don't think that low and middle income
people should be targeted for tax rises
in states I think where there needs to
be additional funds going into the
system they should be coming from those
with the broadest shoulders and we have
seen an increase in income and wealth
inequality over recent years I think a
strong public support for where there
needs to be that additional contribution
that coming from those with the broader
shoulders I'm just trying to talk about
specifics because it's one thing to say
that those with the broader shoulders
should pay more I'm sure most people
would agree with that what do you mean
when you say that you think that we
should be looking at taxes on assets you
talked about taxes on savings you talked
about tax and housings what are you
talking about what Sophie as I said
before this is in the context of that
debate where government seems to have
intimated that it would be seeking to be
potentially raising taxes on all of the
population no I don't think that's right
I think it should be
targeted now I'm not going to save to
you to spell out exactly how that should
work I think that's time it's a
government way no sleeping with your new
hello Chancellor it feels to me like
this is an important debate to have and
frankly I don't really know what you're
talking like we talked about taxing
assets but what you mean would a Labour
government consider taxing people
savings or people's houses well as I
said that debate would only arise at the
stage if we needed additional
contributions into the system I'm hoping
that we won't see the continued
reduction in the size of our economy
actually it's best if we can draw our
ear to this crisis but if there needs to
be an increased contribution then it
should be coming from those with the
broadest shoulders and when we look at
what's happened to the tax system this
applies across a whole variety of
elements of taxation of the very best of
people that has gone down I think you'd
find very few economists who would
disagree with that and yet support for
the lowest income people in the middle
income people has been reduced at the
same time that's not a fair settlement
and government should be taking a
different approach rather than briefing
out suggesting that for example income
tax could be increased for everyone in
the population they should be looking at
those with the broadest shoulders making
more of a contribution I think that's
really important I think I'm struggling
to find out really what you meant by the
assets but it's the first time that I've
interviewed some I'm quite keen to kind
of get a bit of a sense about your sort
of vision I guess the kind of Chancellor
that you would like to be if you were in
that job now I interviewed your
predecessor John McDonald last year he
said that he'd like to see a socialist
society I want to see a transformed
economy so not capitalism as it now
operates so do you also want to redefine
capitalism are you a socialist what I
want to see is a much fairer society I
want to see a society where we don't
have for example hospital porters living
you know in my city in Oxford we've got
Hospital porters who are living in
single rooms in houses and Multiple
Occupation
who if they have their bike stolen for
example you know I've heard one of them
in tears in front of me pand I knocked
on his door but that to me you know I we
need to see a change away from that kind
of a society we've seen how the lack of
financial resilience of so many people
in the UK has been enormous ly
problematic during this crisis you know
we entered it with a quarter of UK
families not even having 100 pounds in
savings we need a change to that now
some people would call that socialism
some people would call it fairness
what's most important to me is that we
actually get that changed that we don't
ever enter a crisis again with so many
families in our country struggling now
moving on one of the biggest challenges
it feels to me facing us as we start the
recovery from coronaviruses convincing
people that it's safe to send their
children back to school I went to a
school for example in West Sussex just
two weeks ago where he said that it was
a real challenge actually making pupils
and their parents feel that it was safe
to return to the classroom and labour
has been a bit criticized for not saying
that children should be back in the
classroom sooner now in May you
suggested that you wouldn't be happy to
send your child back to school without
more evidence that by doing so
coronavirus wouldn't be spread it would
be more than happy to send my own child
back to school if I knew that by doing
so I would not be potentially harming
others we don't have that evidence we
don't have that evidence in front of us
now was that helpful comment for a
Shadow Chancellor to make well actually
you know it's very very interesting case
this because very very quickly and maybe
it's something slightly more to do with
women politicians I don't know very very
quickly people suggested that as a
result of that I wouldn't be sending my
child back to school you just quoted my
words and I didn't actually say that at
all I said that I believe that parents
needed more evidence I said that we
needed to have a proper strategy around
this one that involved teachers and
parents working together with government
and that immediately got turned into
something personal about me as it was my
son wasn't even in the age group that
would have been going back at that time
he has now gone back to school is one of
many children who have but you'll be
aware that there are many many other
families
who don't yet have confidence in the
system we've got to have a grip on this
from government time and time again we
urged government to work with teachers
to work with local authorities to make
sure that we had that process towards
reopening they've suggested that they
will be starting to have that process
now now it's very very late it's far too
slow but at least it's been put in place
now in advance of September and we're
really saying to them that you've got to
concentrate on this because having so
many children who are not in school
obviously it's bad for those children
but of course I'm aware of the fact that
it means so many parents are not able to
go back to work if they're able to
because they just don't have that
childcare there they don't have their
children being in school so it's
something government critically needs to
get a grip on okay now we are running at
a time but I'm keen just to ask one
final question on the Chinese telecoms
giant huawei reports in the papers this
morning the government is going to start
beginning a process of removing its
involvement from the 5g network is that
the right decision well we've been
seeing that government needs to have a
proper strategy around this for many
many months we were told that there was
going to be an approach to try and work
out a more diversified approach to our
telecoms infrastructure to try and make
sure that there wouldn't be a reliance
on some of the very very major players
where there might be these security
issues now that strategy was not
forthcoming now there seems to have been
some suggestions today and they seem to
be kind of leaks and I'm not sure of
whether they've been verified or not
that there might be a different approach
being taken you know we really don't
want to have policy being made in this
kind of lurching manner we need to have
a long-term strategy our communications
infrastructure is really important for
this country we've obviously seen that
particularly over the last few weeks so
government needs to be looking at this
in a much longer time frame work rather
than seemingly being driven by you know
as I say these kind of lurch
okay thank you very much for being on
the program this morning much
appreciated